[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
donald trump aún no le concede la
victoria a joe biden lo que él califica
como una vergüenza el presidente
estadounidense denuncia sin pruebas un
supuesto fraude electoral e inició una
guerra legal con la que logró que los
votos de georgia donde aún está por
definir una contienda clave que podría
determinar las mayorías del senado sean
recontados manualmente
y brasil elige a sus autoridades locales
la campaña se convierte en un auténtico
carnaval lleno de personajes muy
originales que les mostramos con
nuestras corresponsales
deja vu en perú por tercera vez en
cuatro años el congreso destituyó al
presidente los ciudadanos rechazan la
destitución con protestas en las calles
revisamos 20 años de inestabilidad
política en el país suramericano
y empezamos en eeuu donald trump se
niega a conceder la presidencia pese a
que los resultados dicen claramente que
joe biden es el ganador generalmente se
trata de una formalidad pero si el
presidente de trump continúa negando se
podría complicar la transición del poder
en la democracia más antigua del planeta
con sus acciones legales el equipo de
abogados del mandatario ya logró que los
votos de georgia sean recontados
manualmente algo que no significa nada
para la contienda presidencial pero sí
podría representar algo en la carrera
por el senado donde republicanos y
demócratas compiten por la mayoría
veamos el siguiente informe
todo era alegría y alivio para los
demócratas en georgia después de que yo
bailé en lograr a una ajustada mayoría
la semana pasada pero otra vez todo está
en juego en el conocido como el estado
melocotón debido a que la carrera es tan
ajustada que las autoridades ordenaron
un conteo manual y aunque la carrera por
la presidencia ya está definida la
contienda sigue por el senado
ambas sillas del estado están en juego
con los republicanos david verdú y kelly
löffler defendiendo sus puestos en
contra de jong o soft y raphael warnock
el próximo 5 de enero después de que
ningún candidato asegurara el 50 por
ciento necesario
en washington los demócratas sólo les
faltan dos sillas en el senado para que
éste quede dividido a la mitad si hay
este empate la decisión recae sobre la
vicepresidente que en enero será kamala
harris por lo que es probable que le dé
la mayoría de votos para aprobar
cualquier proyecto a los demócratas
harris paso a los días previos a la
campaña en georgia destacando los
asuntos clave para los votantes como el
movimiento black life matters y el
cuidado de la salud debido a la crisis
de kobe 19 que atraviesa
algo que también hizo central en su
campaña veces wajdi ser o no ser salvado
este es el por qué esta contienda por el
senado es vital porque la corte suprema
podría derogar lo y luego sería el
congreso el que decida cómo legislar
sobre las condiciones preexistentes para
que tengan cubrimiento y si mitch
mcconnell y david perdió y que el hilo
flare son determinantes en el curso de
la política y luego permitan a la corte
suprema- legislar para eliminar esa
protección a las condiciones
preexistentes
jackson prince distinguen de ellos han
pasado 20 años desde que una de las
sillas de georgia se hizo azul sin
embargo las campañas de los demócratas
como stage y abrams han ganado algunos
votantes ahí algunos expertos creen que
la reciente sacudida puede ser decisiva
para el país llevándolo a girar a la
izquierda vamos a brasil más de 150
millones de personas escogen los
alcaldes vicealcaldes y concejales de
los 5.500 68 municipios del gigante
suramericano la jornada está marcada por
la pandemia del cob y 19 que podría
afectar la asistencia a las urnas por su
diversidad cultural la campaña en brasil
se transforma en un
cuando aparecen candidatos originales y
fantasiosos en el estado de minas gerais
el rangers verde promete renovar el
espectro político con idealismo y buenas
intenciones más que con sus superpoderes
veamos el informe de valeria sacó de
augusta el lunar
[Música]
podría parecer que es carnaval pero en
realidad esta es la campaña para las
elecciones locales en brasil
reinier verde y voy a cambiar la
política de youssef ahora es una de las
ciudades principales del estado de minas
gerais a pesar del disfraz de superhéroe
runner song se toma muy a pecho su papel
mi personaje no es una simple caricatura
es un trabajo que hago desde hace 7 años
en mi ciudad un servicio voluntario en
el que visitó escuelas guarderías y
hospitales y entiende eso de que no soy
un payaso en la política que entre sus
propuestas estrella potenciar la
educación y la salud y crear una oficina
virtual para agilizar la administración
pública a todos los capítulos en la
televisión en la calle son muchos los
que piden hacerse una foto con el power
rangers
ya no estamos procurando lo que es
normal estamos buscando un superhéroe
para ver qué se puede hacer en la
política porque básicamente hemos
perdido todas las esperanzas que brasil
tiene una larga tradición de folklore
electoral ya hubo candidatos que
encarnaron a jesús y al [__] a bin
laden y a rambo en 1988 un mono de
zoológico fue postulado para la alcaldía
de río de janeiro fue una provocación
que consiguió 400.000 votos y el mono
thiago estuvo a punto de ser elegido hay
candidatos que aprovechan las elecciones
para dar un empujón a sus negocios y a
su imagen otros aparecen solo para
explicar el sistema y usan eso como
capital político para intentar una
candidatura de no necesariamente para
vencer la mayoría está aquí solo para
participar en las fiestas la
carnavalización de la política en brasil
tiene los días contados los grandes
eventos electorales con distribución de
regalos fueron prohibidos más allá de
las candidaturas excéntricas estos
comicios servirán para saber si se
mantiene la polarización entre
y detractores del presidente y jair
bolsonaro sigamos en brasil para revisar
otras noticias del continente que usted
debería conocer esta semana
el presidente ya ir bolsonaro desató una
polémica al afirmar que hay sectores que
buscan atemorizar con una segunda ola
del cob y 19 que ya ha dejado más de 160
mil muertes en el país con palabras
soeces pidió a los ciudadanos entender
que mantener la salud de la economía es
más importante
todo ahora es pandemia tenemos que
acabar con eso lo siento por todos los
que han muerto 200 todos vamos a morir
algún día todos vamos a morir tú vas a
morir algún día no tiene sentido
intentar escapar de la realidad
tenemos que dejar de ser un país de
mariquitas sé que estoy dando de comer a
la prensa
y el ex presidente evo morales regresó
triunfante a bolivia luego de que su
ministro de economía luis arce asumiera
el poder y de que la justicia anulara la
orden de detención que el gobierno
interino había impuesto en su contra por
supuesto fraude electoral en las
elecciones de 2019
ahora les dijo que regresó al país a
dedicarse a la vida que tenía antes de
llegar al poder es decir como
sindicalista en menos de un año hemos
recuperado la democracia en menos de un
año hemos vuelto al gobierno con más y
psp eso es algo inédito algo histórico
algo único yo di del mundo
y las protestas contra los feminicidios
en méxico llegaron hasta la capital
luego de que alguna manifestación en
cancún fuera reprimida con balas reales
los manifestantes salieron a las calles
de la turística localidad para rechazar
la violencia contra las mujeres en el
país norteamericano luego de la
desaparición de una mujer el fin de
semana pasado las autoridades han
reportado un aumento de los feminicidios
del 9.2 por ciento en 2020
[Música]
pero es el responsable quien es el autor
e intelectual que dio la orden
y quienes llevaron a cabo esas acciones
cuando un asunto así
se debe
de actuar
sin contemplaciones
no debe haber impunidad no deber
protección a nadie
vamos a perú porque sigue la
inestabilidad política en medio de
acusaciones de corrupción los
legisladores destituyeron al presidente
martín vizcarra por supuesta incapacidad
moral un mecanismo de la constitución
que había sido creado para ser utilizado
en caso de que un presidente enfermara o
sufriera un accidente pero que algunos
denuncian es utilizado para llevar a
cabo golpes de estado los ciudadanos se
manifestaron en las calles en contra de
la juramentación de manuel merino el
presidente del congreso como mandatario
merino terminará el mandato de vizcarra
que irá hasta julio de 2021 cuando asuma
el presidente que se ha elegido en abril
vizcarra a su vez iba a terminar el
mandato de pedro pablo kuczynski quien
también fue destituido en el congreso
revisemos 20 años de crisis en perú en
el informe de andrés gonzález
[Aplausos]
ocho presidentes en 20 años la muestra
de una convulsa realidad política en
perú en noviembre de 2002 eventos casi
paralelos ocurrían en tokio y en lima a
la vez siento mucho que está
causado
30 incertidumbre
construcción
e incluso inclinación
mientras el entonces presidente alberto
fujimori se anunciaba el congreso lo
destituía argumentando actos de
corrupción e incapacidad moral
permanente
sí
[Música]
y por la paz tras la salida de fujimori
el presidente del congreso valentín
paniagua asumió de manera interina como
mandatario unos meses después el
opositor alejandro toledo ganó las
elecciones
pero la estabilidad no llegó durante su
mandato el país quedó paralizado por
semanas de huelgas en diciembre de 2003
toledo exigió la renuncia de todos sus
ministros para desactivar un escándalo
de tráfico de influencias que
involucraba a su primera ministra
beatriz merino no avanzaremos sino
iniciamos un punto de quiebre al
interior del gobierno
a toledo lo sucedería un viejo conocido
de la política peruana en julio de 2006
volvía al poder el ex presidente alan
garcía tras dos años al mando su
gabinete tuvo que renunciar para impedir
la aprobación de un nuevo voto de
censura en el congreso por recibir pagos
a cambio de concesiones a la compañía
noruega discover petroleum
en junio de 2011 el militar retirado de
izquierda ollanta humala ganó por un
estrecho margen a la hija del ex
presidente alberto fujimori keiko se
convirtió así en el primer gobernante
izquierdista en perú en 36 años
que suscribió la patria que ejerceré
fielmente en 2016
keiko fujimori perdió de nuevo unas
elecciones presidenciales esta vez ante
el ex banquero de woolwich pedro pablo
kuczynski
pese la derrota su partido consiguió una
amplia mayoría en el congreso iniciando
así una guerra entre el ejecutivo y el
legislativo que terminó con la renuncia
de kuczynski y la llegada de martín
vizcarra tras la revelación de unos
audios en los que se evidencian posibles
acuerdos entre kuczynski y los
congresistas fujimoristas para indultar
al ex presidente alberto fujimori a
cambio de no ser destituido
[Aplausos]
2019 sería un año de tragedias y
escándalos en abril el ex presidente
alan garcía se suicidó cuando iba a ser
arrestado en la investigación de los
sobornos de la compañía o de 'break'
en septiembre vizcarra disolvió el
congreso en octubre keiko fujimori fue
enviada a prisión preventiva mientras
que 2020 sería el año de los juicios
políticos en septiembre el congreso
aprobó una moción de censura para
destituir a vizcarra por presuntos
contratos irregulares con un cantante no
me acuerdo
y no lo he hecho antes y no lo voy a
hacer ahora
pero poco después de salir airosos
comenzó el proceso en noviembre donde
finalmente se aprobó su destitución
cuídense mucho de el coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]